thank you
uh welcome everyone and welcome to
anyone that's
ending on youtube
right can i have uh apologies
please there are no apologies thank you
very much
a confirmation of minutes that's ages
three
to seven i'll run through the pages for
me
at page three
[Music]
page four
page five
h6
thank you proposed by councillor clark
seconded
by
[Music]
again
[Music]
declarations of interest members with
interest declare should refer to the
agenda item
and describe the nature of their
interests and the item is being
considered
four agreements of agenda between
part one and two
thank you councillor clark secondary
councillor hawkins all those in favor
thank you uh urgent matters
um to be bought for by commissioner the
chair
i just have a couple today uh
one is that you'll notice the absence of
rich clark
who is now moved out of the area he was
a much
valued member parish member of this
committee
and he helped me a lot i know he helped
a lot of my predecessors
and he really really enjoyed the
standards committee
um which is really nice
and somehow we've got to try to find
some money to replace him
any of you know a parish counsellor that
would really
like to be involved um please
just let uh speak to you now
thank you and the other one is just to
um
helly are you new to the youtube
committee have you always been
on it i'm new to a chair i thought you
were playing
thank you
[Music]
right now we come to item six to review
amendments
to best practice uh i asked stacy to
introduce this for us
it's been some time since we had the
last standards from
it and it was agreed that we would
review the
um best practice um that was
in relation to um a consultation that
the government sent
out in relation to standards committees
and sanctions
um but um
unfortunately the review by the
government has has been
delayed um due to the pandemic
um so the recommendations that have come
through um by other consultation
other um toughest actions should be
imposed
um against misconduct by councillors
um so the suggestions thus far
have been that cancers can be
disqualified or
suspended for um reaches of the code of
conduct i suppose depending on
the seriousness of them so it's
uh luke hall the government minister
who's been tasked with undertaking
review um and he's said that it's now
been delayed due to the pandemic
um but they hope to respond shortly
so i i thought from torridge's
perspective i don't know if the
committee will be in agreement with this
that
it may be preferable for us to await the
outcome of the
government's review and their proposals
before we look at our own
um best practice and code of conduct um
because otherwise potentially
we may be in the rounds of augmenting it
twice but
obviously i'll put that out to members
um
and obviously i'll update committee as
soon as we we have a
formal response from the government yes
i think this
is being held up by kobe but we find
ourselves
with almost no sanctions really at the
moment is that
that's the case it's not real
you have sanctions but but um
we don't have powers to suspend um
counsellors or
or remove them certainly um sanctions at
the moment
are items such as they can be you can
recommend they be removed from
certain committees recommend they've
been removed from their
role as as group leader recommends that
they
are excluded from from council buildings
and so there are certainly
recommendations but there's there's no
further sanctions other than that yeah
thank you okay
[Music]
obviously they have huge input into this
but
i think the lga council brenton aren't
supporting tougher
um sanctions um it says says here
actually
um the leader of the lga
has left twitter due to daily threats of
violence so i i suspect
um they're in support of being able to
impose tougher sanctions on on certain
occasions in fact it says he's been told
he would be
kidnapped shot and have his body dumped
in the sea
as well as having dog extroverted for
his friend
right okay i understand
that that sort of says it all in one way
you don't want to see the new sanctions
because it's we would hope that they
would never be used within this council
anyway
i think it's essential we have them
there if the
serious case does come before us does
anybody else have any thoughts at all
no they're all happy with that
right so we just await them
and we will obviously bring them put
them on an agenda
as soon as we we have anything
definitely
uh right now we've got um item
seven two
um it's quite a long time since i think
we went through it once before
it seems a long time ago um
um yes chair thank you and i've handed
out
a copy of our standards from the hearing
procedure
so that everyone's um got it
um
thing that i have also brought along is
a shortened version which i'll
hand out to members that we use for um
licensing um subcommittees which may be
be helpful um
this issue
thank you stacio i also think that
it may be good if you could to
distribute to
a new independent members the
flow chart that we have re
to reach the hearing is the procedure
that we go through
or the officers go through before it
would arrive
without which is a very thorough
procedure
would you like me to to outline that now
chair would that be handled well i think
i i think it will because um
it's very thorough and opportunities are
there to heal the situation before it
gets to us
and not much gets worse through the hard
work
of stay there
it's i'm very pleased to say it's very
rare that we we get to a standard
committee hearing um so generally
speaking
um a complaint is submitted to me um as
monitoring officer
and we do our best to try and resolve
that those complaints
informally um if if
possible um so the complaint comes in to
me
and then it's always sent to the
councillor because
the council is entitled to see the full
complaint who has complained
um and why and obviously have the right
to respond to
to that complaint we don't
allow um anonymous complaints um
because from our perspective it could be
vexatious um and
you know if if there was any substance
to the complaint that person would have
to ultimately come
forward um to give evidence um to a
hearing
um so what we do is i receive the
complaint from
um from the complainant i send that to
the member to formally respond
um and we also discuss it with an
independent person
so the independent person
is independent from the process they're
there
[Music]
in confidence and by and large it is
usually resolved
at that stage um because um
it's either a misunderstanding or um
you know somebody would like an apology
or something along those lines so we try
not to ramp it up and we negotiate
between the parties to try and bring a
resolution
that everybody's happy with um
there are the odd occasion um where
it can't be resolved through the
informal stage
and that's when we um proceed
under the standards committee hearing
procedure for
standards to ultimately
make a decision on on you know if
there's substance to the complaint
or or not um so
we're very lucky at the moment we
figures across we've got three
independent persons but the
the other independent press martin wall
who isn't here today
he's also a trained mediator um
and he's quite often mediated between
the parties
um which is always you know criminally
beneficial as well
so
members have any any input at this stage
anything you'd like to know
or question
should we have to vote on these review
procedures
so unless there's any um suggested
amendments
um then they've been noted
foreign
is everybody happy at this stage to know
them
then they're not in tablets of stem if
we come across any
anything in the future they can always
be
right i think now it's uh
the forward plan
decide to make board plan it's on page 8
of your agenda
clean sheet here now if anybody
has any particular items they tend to
evolve as we don't go along but at the
moment i don't have anything for the
future plan does anybody here wish to
put anything on it
this is all going too easily here
right right can we just know note the
items that were there today
all right okay all right
all right item nine now i'm sorry to say
to people
on youtube i'm gonna have to say goodbye
to you now
because we're now moving into part two
uh publicly excluding the remainder of
the meeting because
the likely disclosure of accepted
information that as defined
in one of the schedule and 12
a the local government act thank you for
attending
oh yes so can we
take a vote on moving to um
all in favor